hey guys welcome to another episode of
top 5 skywards of the week am cam
Robinson in this this is not set forward
no you are you not set forward I am Lucy
James you're back
you're like invading this show some sort
of hostile takeover well I mean that is
my master plan pretty hostile for the
most part I've just an excerpt all the
time in the office I sit in between them
I know you're here like the the barrier
between our love or something
hey what wait what Bastian wait what I
do why do you bring that up I never said
love anyway guys we have five new mods
and let's get straight to mod number one
hey Lucy welcome to Maude number one and
those are some sexy trees you've got a
problem
hey you don't find tree sexy maybe well
what kind of the way is there I mean but
look at them they're new right pretty
nice yeah this is part of Mon number one
I'm let's call Tamriel Reloaded flora
but it's not just trees Lisi it's not
just trees if we look at the ground
there's also like all this new pretty
like grass and ferns ferns
they look hello fern thing maybe they're
Nettles
Kevin wouldn't wouldn't be stuff anyway
he's immune to all things that sting it
is actually a bunch of locations where
you can really notice this modern effect
this is one of them this is hunter's
rest but Lucy where else if people want
to go and see the this mod really take
over where should they go
my ok so let's go to the entrance to a
white run ok can do hey Lucy there's a
new tree Hey that gave up fast
look at it look at it it's it's
impressively different is that hanging
oh they look at the resolution on there
Oh somehow whoops this is hanging
creation yet I mean the thing is like is
actually it brings up an interesting
point though because when you install
the mod there's different resolution
variants you can install yeah which is
kind of cool so you can choose to have
like performance ones or you can go for
like 2k or 4k I think I've got two K
trees on the go I think these are some
sort of yew trees Lizzie yeah said like
a like a looks like a weeping willow
again Oh may actually maybe that's what
it is it just looks like a sad tree it's
very sad but but it's it's majestic I
like it I like it I like that like the
way the Sun comes through the tree
although I'm not sure if that is because
of the mod on oh my it's combination
Lucy is that a goat that it looks like
an elk no now let's be sure let's just
double check but uh no man oh oh no what
happens I misfired
I swear that normally never happens oh
well oh well I don't think that was a go
anyway but this mod is actually called
goat simulator and here we are Riverwood
now we are looking for a particular goat
what's his name
you see his name is Henry Henry the goat
Henry OH
Oh does it go dragging this Henry uh I'd
go for no no don't kill it well it
didn't do they tell me what his name is
I think I bet if I ask him a question
right in the head Oh woah he made a
noise it is Henry hooray
here we have goat simulator ring okay
and it says start goat simulator 2014
it's Chiron's
so if we take that but here we are yeah
you can like do a jumping attack like
that you can attack with that and you
can also we go to our show we go to
shouts yeah there is Oh
pretty good she's like whoever did this
I'll find him nobody suspects the girl
oh no they suspect the girl shouts oh
look he's striking them with lightning
it's amazing
yes of course it's a lightning storm
hahaha I am thunder goats
now there's one shot we've not used here
which is this bad push let's give this a
go I reckon we can probably throw us
some bodies around for this one
mmm yes yeah it's pretty much you kind
of finger neighbor doing keep the
streets clean but it lets burn the river
yeah it's back to from whence they came
as a people come from right rivers yeah
sure why are they not trying to kill me
whoa that's incredibly powerful like are
we gonna launch so we gotta launch some
more Lisi oh yeah you ready for this
time for you guys to fly oh oh you guys
are so making a mistake
hahaha boy wash [ __ ] he can juggle them
20 of them hey guys
blush lipstick going keep juggling up
this is so good oh my god
alright let's launch this guy wish my
brother oh [ __ ]
I'll see you in another line I hardly
knew you awful what happened to those
other goats
I hope the dog Bush Wow and the great
thing about this mod Lucy is if you're
ty if you tire of being a goat not that
you ever would know just go back at your
inventory find the ring and take it off
and you're Kevin again you know what
this is gonna become a permanent part of
top 5 scary mods of the week that ring -
fantastic - fantastic
alright let's eat every mod number three
which this week is called pick up
weapons fast equipment weapons so feel
like that could be more sissing I think
it could be but basically it's actually
pretty cool it's brand new mod on the
Skyrim Nexus and what it allows you to
do is mid combat like we are right now
if like Kevin here you're unarmed and
you want to like get weapons quick this
mod will actually you pick up weapons
off the floor all right here they come
right so I'm all that gun Denis all I've
got my guns I punch this guy to death
there's a sword now it only works if
it's attached them like this it doesn't
work you can still search him and pick
up the sword but we want to once it like
remove the sword from his person in the
killing process like hopefully we can I
get this guy's a mace there so I still
may so if I hurry how now my hand lay
straight into the hands Bosh and I can
kill him like so high I'm dire huh pick
that up it's mine now and then you can
play this leather game where you kill
each guy with a slightly different
weapon oh wait pickaxe
yes so as you can see with weapons are
lying around
oh yeah he's dead it also works with
them as well so it doesn't have to be
once dropped by your foes oh he dropped
that he legit dropped that yes yeah it's
cool but I feel like I probably wouldn't
use it you know I'm probably just black
use it like once yeah in like the whole
game but at that moment it'll be amazing
you kill someone with an incredible
sword and you go out to mine and then
you'd wield it mid combat and block cha
and it'd be great
hey Lucy welcome to mod number four now
I know you're thinking this is no mod
that's not that's not a monitor that's
clearly a YouTube video it is this is
you're cheating no I'm not because okay
so I'm gonna bet to show you mod which
features some of the armor in this video
and the mod is kind of like a little
promo a way of like getting the word out
about this guy's movie called despair
stalling caps i stolen caps as well yeah
and it's kind of cool I want to show a
bit of it the armor is super awesome so
we're gonna be dressed as that guy in
the middle there and that you can this
guy the evil looking guy in a minute I
think right now that's the only armor
that's available but they do plan
apparently to bring the green armor to
the mod as well so there you go and
we'll put the link in the description
right now so on screen right now even so
you can go check it out and watch it
fill if you like we're going to be this
dude over on the right hand side here
and we're gonna be kicking some ass even
with the same weapon as well
oh sweet pretty cool now listen to get
those armors you need to obviously first
install the mod and then come to
dragon's reach you picked up the step
forward mmm skip I picked up tea and
then once you're in sight you need to
come round down here and up the stairs
and then we need to go out into the
porch
oh what a porch what's your idea so I
think it was in the main stuff it was
whichever oh yeah yeah the one you can
ride yeah yeah I remember I totally
remember that was he in here is he in
this strange chest
what is it strange inside that straight
chest is that armor we were just talking
about there you go so there's a helmet
as well that's quite scary
yeah and the shield and the hammer and
then a couple of variations of the
helmet
on the shield his words to Lake the
Imperial Order hail Imperial the
Imperial is that Imperial spelt wrong is
it Imperial there we go
that's really actually quite scared
that's pretty good we intimidated it's
really damaged I like the kind of like
sword Scratchy's and all the paint marks
and everything oh this is a quick the
hammer as well that's pretty badass now
it's not the whole equipment because
we're still in the Nordic gauntlets the
one actually Garland's for this one yet
same with the boots so it still needs to
my gauntlets and boots but it's pretty
sweet you can squeeze out orange shoes
you kids I think that's what I made that
in my education remind me never to come
to dinner it's hammer time gosh stop oh
oh oh that looks are due Shh
yes whoa whoa yeah BAM there's some
pretty sick hammer skills it kind of
suits Kevin his arm right away I mean
it's more flamboyant than he usually is
but that's okay sometimes you just want
to make a splash on the battlefield
Oh sometimes you want to just do this oh
hey Lucy James time for the final mod of
this week and this one is adorable and
it's a user voted mod and this week it's
called Lizzie garm the husky companion
garm the husky companion which was some
reason we're singing with a Southern
drawl but anyway go define gar we have
to come to the temple of RK and this
particular part in Whiterun obviously
the whole of the Dead was goods line and
there he is
it's norm hey how he's adorable Garn
wins his helm excitement he's eager to
adventure with you well no wonder hey
buddy hey do you do oh he's so friendly
yeah now he's actually got armor on as
well he's alarmed up but there so this
is just one variation of garm there's
lots of different ones you can install
and you can't flick through them on the
fly when you're in game but you can
choose for new sources like a puppy
version as well
there's like an old white version and
it's a couple of others so well we'll
see what this guy can do and then we'll
swaps him in he's off let him go
protect girl arm go kill back out you
got hair on your head go ahead
hey oh he's pretty badass I think oh
you're gonna go they go he's on fire
finish it off yes looking good good
cheer bow there you go yeah we get good
team we sure do
good boy is that his Hall now you can go
in Oh where's he off to no always he's
doing more fighting yeah you saw some
time
oh he's healing himself now still alive
no cheat and heal that let's pause here
they see and we see we see maja as he's
got little balls let's swap em out for a
different version I will see the
difference
here we go this one's this is like cold
ghost I think is the ghost version but
he's got a veneer armor this time cam
who's that it's the puppy version he's
just a mini a mini garm hey pay pay pal
hey yes he's gonna join us good boy he's
so adorable
Hayley see look it's its shadow garm
Reaper of souls the son yet another
version and he is awesome Hayley see
look we got garm
coming up we got chickens I wonder what
could be coming up I mean we're also a
goat we're also a goat okay so I think
as a goat we should probably do do the
honors of that of launching gar me ready
oh he's standing up he's ready it's
ready let's let's go ah bah ah oh no we
still we still equipped our weapon
riding on a quiver of arrows look like a
witch or Harry Potter
alright alright should we give it a go
give it a goat uh-huh did we just one
shot that matter
hahaha only one side a mammoth we should
shout at the chickens because remember
the awesome goat shout we should talk
again it's the chickens I'm ready here
we go I wonder if this might not set
them off let's find out
no I it was great it was great it's just
a real go simulator we bad well Lucy
James who knew being a goat would be so
much fun not not I thought you've never
been a goat before
no would you consider it again I would
the only experience I've had with goat
is the one time going to a farm yeah you
tried to eat my coat
really goats love coats also oats anyway
um time for the questions and comments I
on warrior one I guess I am war here
with second question for seven kam not
me sorry Lizzie but you can join it
Shelby said you'll be selkie babe either
of you had to be a Skyrim character or
NPC besides Kevin who would you be
I might be ferrand our secret fire
because I know he's a bit of a nerd but
but he has like all the spells and like
lots of money and the power to do lots
of things so I think I would probably
choose him I probably be Cicero yeah
that weird little gesture why would you
like about him he's just really bizarre
he's pretty bizarre of all the elavil
the NPC's of Skyrim he sticks out just
because he was so yeah yeah I agree
okay good good call good call next
question next question Micah viewers
died by the way so I can't read them
anymore it's all on you you see no
pressure okay this one's quite long it's
a hits room Mike plays it so you guys
asked for new intros last week that's
true yeah we did we did Mike plays it
has obliged best intro ever ellipses you
can do a William Wallace type deal with
cam laid out on the table and step could
be over him holding a vibrating
controller maybe after a chicken launch
saying just say merci and it will all
stop just say it one simple word and
that's when cam will let him know that
he wants to speak and several announce
to the camera that cam would like to
speak and claim mercy then cam can take
a deep breath and yell
Skyrim what actually I'll feel the last
comment which I will who these are from
death stir-fry says simply please don't
let Lucy pick a shitty theme again I
didn't pick any C's mods don't worry
guys didn't let Lucy pick the most this
week although I don't understand like
where's you got this reputation for
picking bad mods you picked good mods ok
great mom remember the time I picked the
Mass Effect one of my second ones ago
kids see Lois those other times probably
but this week not because this is not
good at it but just because I was doing
the mods this week I picked a good one
there's pretty good pretty good ones
great you want next time in fact next
week I'll be Lucy and Seb so you can be
you may redeem yourself and
what's-his-name stir-fries eyes mr. Frey
and yeah yes Brett your second father oh
I'm so sorry Steph right Wow
I don't know don't you we've been on a
Jenny Diaz crushes it coming we sure
have let's see you know what else is a
journey of sorts voting voting voting
your voting form on its voting provides
so um can you bring up the list of mods
please Lucy and we'll have a look
through so number one what have we got
I'll take this you take this the
playable frost giant oh yeah I mean we
played his goats that was fun the next
logical step is of course yeah it goes
go frost giant chicken like that's
that's the natural order of things
okay cool so that's what number one if
you want that one deburr two for the
vote is the null door content pack and
this is kind of like Lord of the Rings
inspired Elfie Armour if you like elves
and armor and Lord of the Rings that's
probably good call I love all those
things and number three then is finally
the hillside shelter no this is like
this is a really simple player home but
it's one again it's really popular cuz
apparently it's being crafted in such a
way that it's not just like a copy-paste
of other buildings of scare and like
it's been really reworked so currently
it's really great so if you like a
relaxing hillside shelter then that you
should really vote for one thing for
three
well thanks Lucy um now if people want
to vote how do they do that
they go to tinyurl.com slash ready savvy
bloggers kid you remember and if you
want to suggest mods to me or say abour
lucy and the best way to do that is over
twitter I'm at Camp France Rob Lucy's at
at least James it's james games on of
course is ready semi go to if i just
send him abuse for not being on the show
this week that'd be great alright Lucy
well there's been a pleasure to mod with
you for the first time I hope we mod
again soon
and next time I will let you choose all
the mods and I'm sure they'll be
wonderful oh god I'm gonna read that and
guys thanks for watching remember let us
know what you think of the show and if
you have more do you want us to showcase
that aren't in the vote then send them
to us as well and you can always use it
to our hashtag GA skyrim as well which
it didn't mentioned earlier we'll find
him we'll find a way to find him alright
thanks Lucy thanks Kevin thanks goat
that was weird
thanks cam yeah he's the greatest we'll
see you guys next week
you